good to chat with you Lincoln Riley how
are you sir I have great rates thanks
for having me on
you bet absolutely what is it like
around those parts in a week where
you're taking on Texas
yeah it's unlike any other week you know
it's just a different buzz and vibe
around the around the community this is
an important game it's such a historic
game and and traditionally a great game
and so you know you can kind of feel it
in the air you know it's one that you
know when you come coach or play at
Oklahoma you look forward to this one at
each and every year and how do you make
it different for the kids what do you do
put it up in red letters or something
like that let me through how you make
how you impress upon these young men
about this game well for us it's it's
you know we've got away a little bit
from the notion that this is just like
any other game you know three years ago
when I came here I I kind of tried that
myself and it's and it's wrong you know
it's it's it is still football it's
still 11 on 11 all that good stuff but
it is also a different kind of intensity
a different kind of atmosphere the game
is you know as good as college football
kits and so I think you gotta embrace it
and that's what we've done here the last
couple of years we've really embraced
the the how different this game is what
it takes to win it and you know and
hopefully you could do that and have a
chance to win there in the fourth
quarter on Saturday yeah I know it's
it's it's always a rarity when you can
take part in a series that were that can
be of which can be said first matchup
1900 you know I mean that's there's not
many of those no doubt I mean you think
about all the great coaches and players
that have you know you know gone down
there's a Cotton Bowl each October and
then gone attic historic games you know
being at the same venue each year you
get the Texas State Fair around it I
mean it's just there's nothing else like
in sports there's really not
Lincoln riling here on the Rich Eisen
show okay so did you at all speak to
Kyler's Murray about how he might have
been in that wild-card game last night
for the Saturday so he probably would
have made a difference so knowing him
yeah I know I mean he's he's supremely
talented what is that like having a kid
that you know
is in a sport where obviously you need
him to be a guy who plays with a the
head on his shoulders but also some
reckless abandon knowing that he's also
got a baseball career he might be
thinking of yeah you know it's been
great I mean we've had great
communication with him and and he's a
football player I mean there's no doubt
about it when he's here it's all and
there's nothing about baseball he's
gonna be you know he's gonna be smart
like we went all our quarterbacks to be
when we want him to stay healthy and
have a chance to play well like our guys
have done in the past but at the same
time you you can't play this game scared
you cannot play this game hesitant and
play it at the level that we expect to
play so he's uh he's done a great job
and really honestly we just trained like
every other player and I think that's
the only way he would have it and how
has he handled obviously taking the
position a year after one of the most
famous players in the history of the
school held it coach he's handled it
great you know I've been really proud of
him he's commanded our group you know
he's obviously played at an extremely
high level and then the thing I've
probably been the most proud of is he
hasn't he hasn't tried to be anybody but
himself you know and he was you know I
think he's got a good mental makeup to
be able to handle that because he's very
confident he has a lot of self-belief
but he also you know he's just he's just
going to be himself and he learned from
Baker he'd be first to say it there's a
lot of things he'll take but he's he
still just got to be Kyler and I think
that's the most important thing when
you're taking over for somebody like
that and and he's playing at a very high
level because of it well you're used to
coaching a quarterback who's got a
confident level and self I'm wondering
if you in terms of watching what Baker
Mayfield did the other night and what he
is meaning to a Cleveland fan base right
off the bat what what is your what are
your emotions that you you have coming
off of a long talent evaluation portion
in which virtually every peccadillo
that has been mentioned about Baker
Mayfield was picked upon
yeah I mean I'm I felt like it was
coming the whole time and so I guess it
I don't know it's invalidates is the
right word because I think you know what
he did err speaks for itself and what he
did for this program speaks for itself
but I always felt like that there you
know there was no reason that the guy
couldn't be successful I mean I always
felt like that and and that he would be
in the right situation at any level
including the NFL so I think everybody
seeing that you know he can come out of
an offense like this and go succeed
which is you know picking up steam in
the NFL right now he's not 64 you know
what that's okay that that's not a
prerequisite to be a great quarterback
and he's a he's a team guy you know and
you see how he galvanized that team he
handled me in the backup well and you
know I think has given them a lot of
life in energy here's the starter so
what what I guess red flag that you
heard being mentioned about Baker
Mayfield from January all the way
through to draft day do you think is the
most glaring I guess what's the word for
it I'm gonna come up with the right for
most unfair most glaring unfair red flag
that you thought was associated with
they can they fill coach well I mean he
obviously is that you know had a few
issues off the field I mean we all know
that so I I understand some of those red
flags
it wasn't a concern for me here I don't
think it'll be a concern in the NFL he's
a team first guys but I do get that
probably honestly on the field which
would be his intelligence on the field
and then how great of a thrower the guy
is and I think a lot of people thought
he just dink and thinkin dumped it
around here which which wasn't the case
and they see him making elite throws at
the NFL level and they see him you know
going and picking up a system quickly
and able to produce at a high level very
very early in his career Lincoln Riley
Oklahoma head coach here in the Rich
Eisen show and I loved your tweet after
the Thursday Night Football victory over
the Jets for Baker honestly like in
Cleveland hey bud bet they forgive you
for planting the flag now Congrats at
Baker Mayfield hashtag
you DNA that now how long did you have
that one in the chute don't you know and
honestly I didn't have it at all and we
were watching the game and at home
there's my wife flexing a game and it
was unfolding and we just we one of us
made a comment that just in that so
funny that you know doing this here
Cleveland you know with obviously what
happened at Ohio State last year and and
it kind of came to my mind right there
at the end and I thought well you know
what if they win this thing this would
be you know this would be pretty funny
to tweet out just the irony of it and
and so yeah I wasn't into throwing shade
it was just meant to have some fun with
it because it is it's actually a pretty
cool story you know and and to go from
you know not everybody but to go from
almost billing in that state to hero in
that state it's in such a short amount
of time it's pretty amazing well that's
why I always thought that it would be a
wise choice by the Browns or at least
when they made it that it would be one
they wouldn't regret despite what the
instant snap analysis of Baker being
number one overall was coach is that a
franchise that had not won a game in as
long as they had not won a game needs
Baker to plant a flag in places like
Heinz Field against the Steelers needs
to plant a flag like he needs to do this
week against the Baltimore Ravens to let
everybody know that it's different
around here I couldn't agree more you
gotta have somebody that's you know what
you're saying and what I'm saying is you
know somebody that's not scared of the
moment and it's not scared of the
challenge and it's ready to embrace it
and believes that they could be a part
and open get it turned around and if you
need this and he is your guy well then I
guess them what is the biggest challenge
for you this weekend moving forward five
and oh I mean everybody sees your
competition nationally what they look
like from Alabama who's Heisman Trophy
candidate quarterback has yet to throw a
pass in the fourth quarter yet with what
Ohio State has looked like I mean what
is your challenge coach I just this game
in itself this is this game come up we
said earlier it's unlike any other it
doesn't matter you know how the teams
are playing coming in none of that
matters it's just it's its own it's it's
like its own classification of games
really it's it's such a heavy hitter
it's always you know a tight game
both teams are going to probably play
the best ball that they play all year so
it's you know it's a unique game it's
always a challenge to win at Texas
obviously you know playing you know
playing very well and so you know very
very talented roster and very good
football team so I'm sure it's going to
be like just all these others that we've
had heavy-hitting going to be a tight
game both teams are going to play well
and you know that's that's what you
would expect in a game like this and
you're from the state of Texas you're
your Texas Tech guy I mean are there
people in the Riley family or on the
family tree that might not be rooting
for you this weekend maybe some distant
relatives but they're not getting any
Christmas presents okay should that just
want to make sure that everything's all
fine and Plus you know up so you
obviously know the rivalry from that end
as well and being a Texas Tech guy and
being there when Mike Leach was there as
your coach and then on his staff I got
to ask you your favorite safe for work
potentially Mike Leach story that you
can tell here on the Rich Eisen show Oh
probably the I was a graduate assistant
in his office as probably was mm mmm for
cellphone rings the answers the phone I
was in there talking to him doing some
work same time he starts talking to the
guy conversation goes on like 30 minutes
which is you know for him as a short
conversation and and you could tell
eventually that the phone cuts out one
of them looks service they can't hear
each other so he clicks the phone like
it was back when you had the old flip
phone so he flips it back open redials
resumed hey I got you now sorry bad
connection they resumed the talk talked
for about another 30 minutes hang up
after the talk I just kind of in passing
said hey don't you be talking to he said
all they had the wrong number for 30
minutes and then called them back you
know so that's oh hey that's Mike you
know that's Mike Loong the wrong number
the wrong number yeah or they're calling
from and just just there he goes yeah
did you hear his quote this week on
balanced offense did you hear that
I'm heard that one for a long time but
it's still pretty close he's had his
math wrong the entire time that 50% and
50% is 50% stupid yeah I'm surprised he
got that wrong but I think well I think
we'd get the point I do coach thanks for
the time really appreciate it
and I look forward to having you back on
again all right thank you right back at
you Lincoln Reilly the head coach of
Oklahoma football a Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience